morning the un secretary general antonio
gutierrez is now going to involve
himself directly in an effort to solve
the ukraine war
on tuesday he called for a truce over
orthodox easter something that russia
has not agreed to but on the same day he
also sent two letters one to the
russians and the other to the ukrainians
requesting that he should visit moscow
and kiev the first of those trips will
now be on tuesday all we have on the
agenda is his working lunch and meeting
with the foreign minister and then his
reception later on on the same day by
president putin you know as he said in
his letters to both presidents
he hopes to talk about what can be done
to bring peace to ukraine urgently
diplomats speaking to me before the
moscow visit was officially confirmed
welcome the secretary general's new
peace initiative welcome any effort to
to address this ongoing problem but i
think the big issue is to ensure that
the russians abide by ceasefire that
they also
allow for access to to civilians but any
effort to in the carnage is welcome you
are absolutely delighted to see the
secretary general step forward he has
been
very strong in his remarks to date we
now need to see action and i think the
suggestions that he's put out there in
terms of engaging both parties brings
the u.n to into the role that it
properly assumes in its responsibility
for international peace and security
before the start of the war the
secretary general had tried to meet
president putin they were both at the
winter olympics in china at the same
time then russian officials said it
wasn't possible to arrange a meeting now
the secretary general finds himself
possibly involved in shuttle diplomacy
between moscow and kiev without doubt
this is the most important and probably
the most difficult trip of his five
years in office james bay's al jazeera
at the united nations